we're overwhelmed we're connected 24/7
most of us have information flowing in
multiple channels our calendars are
packed our task lists they're long to
overflowing and this is what I call the
busyness epidemic that's consuming us so
there becomes in our society this like
busyness badge where we all need to be
overstuffed over scheduled because that
in our culture is how you demonstrate
value and how you demonstrate that
you're needed and important that's not
necessarily the case
every time you say yes you're saying no
to something else so the whole point is
to get really clear around what you want
to say yes to and what you want to say
no to because every time you say yes you
end up with a calendar that's full to
overflowing many of the things that
might be in it are really not in
alignment with you and who you are and
so know becomes a powerful tool to take
back control of your time in your day
and our hesitation was saying no is we
think maybe we're gonna disappoint them
or we're not gonna be able to move
forward in our career well that's not
true if you say no I can't do this
project right now because I'm working on
X can I get to it later you're now
having your manager as this key
stakeholder helping you make some
decisions and prioritize your workload
and you're letting them know what you're
working on because a lot of the time
they don't know so you're know empowers
others to help you as you're helping
yourself but we're also very short and
sweet and are no we don't give them a
list of reasons why you aren't saying
I'd love to but I've got this and that
because then they might come back to you
and say oh but it's only gonna take a
few minutes it's only gonna take a
couple of days you want to be very short
and succinct and you're know and then
gracefully decline and remember that
it's not always about you you know that
you're know is not necessarily going to
ruin their day they'll probably go and
ask someone else and be just fine so I
think what happens with the busyness
epidemic is you get so caught up in the
doing of your day just moving through
the meetings moving through the tasks
that you forget that we're not human
doings
we're human being
and so some of the vitality and the
beauty in life you just miss because
your heads down and you're constantly
responding and reacting to what
everything else is going on in your
world it's in that space of the poles or
a little bit of white space on your
calendar that that's where I think you
can find those little moments of joy and
meaning